[Musique]
je
m
d
[Musique]
vous savez où nous sommes
en fait nous sommes aujourd'hui sur le
territoire de la réserve marine donc
c'est une réserve nationale qui a pour
but en fait de préserver les récifs
coralliens de la réunion et tous les
écosystèmes associés depuis le cap là
aussi jusqu'à l'étang salé donc en fait
cette terre marine protégée c'est la
seule à l'île de la réunion et elle
permet en fait de préserver ces
écosystèmes
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe de 14 personnes
et nous avons plusieurs missions dont il
ya une équipe de surveillance et de
police avec cinq personnes dont deux
responsables une équipe de
sensibilisation et d'éducation avec
quatre personnes un responsable et trois
guides animateurs et nous avons
également et l'équipe scientifique avec
une responsable et une assistante et une
équipe administrative
avec une responsable et une assistante
de direction ainsi que moi même en tant
que directrice
[Musique]
sur ce territoire marin nous avons la
chance d'avoir une grande biodiversité
marine à la réunion avec plus de 3500
espèces animales et végétales qui ont
été recensés à ce jour sachant que nous
avons encore beaucoup d'espacé à
découvrir que nous ne connaissons pas
encore
[Musique]
que nous avons plusieurs types d'actions
au sein des réserves marines nous avons
comme je vous le dis comme une cellule
de sensibilisation d'éducation nous
avons des actions de sensibilisation
nous avons un sentier sous marin donc
c'est un sentier guidée avec un guide
animateur qui vous emmène en ballade en
fait sous marine qui vous explique en
fait les écosystèmes coralliens leur
formation mais aussi les pressions qui
s'exercent sur les récifs coralliens
nous avons aussi beaucoup d'actions de
pédagogie avec les scolaires et mais
également avec le grand public
nous sommes aussi à beaucoup de stands
la fête de la mer la fête de la science
etc nous avons aussi beaucoup d'action
scientifiques pour préserver un milieu
il faut aussi le connaître donc nous
menons nous en régie plusieurs suivi et
monitoring notamment le suivi l'état de
santé des récifs mais nous travaillons
aussi beaucoup en partenariat avec les
autres senti scientifiques au niveau
local à l'échelle nationale et
internationale
et enfin il ya aussi beaucoup d'actions
de
sensibilisation des usagers par rapport
à la réglementation est malheureusement
quelquefois aussi des actions de police
pour ceux qui ne respectent pas cette
réglementation
[Musique]
les rôles des agents au sein de la
réserve naturelle marine donc déjà on
est composée de huit agents donc cinq
qui sont affectés propre à la cellule
surveillance et police et trois à la
cellule éducation sensibilisation
donc notre mission elle est de
surveiller ces zones de réserves donc de
constater les infractions et aussi
surtout de renseigner les usagers sur
les gestes à faire et à ne pas faire
donc c'est vrai qu'on est confronté
depuis plusieurs années à avec une
augmentation de des infractions
d'optique soit au niveau de bêche ou au
niveau nautique donc on est là pour
essayer justement délimiter ces
infractions en sensibilisant les usagers
sur sur les ja s'affairent à être sur le
terrain justement pour que les gens ils
nous voient ils savent que dans cette
réserve là il faut faire très attention
que les milieux il est il est fragile et
donc
du lundi au dimanche en passant par les
nuits on essaie de couvrir justement le
maximum d'horaires pour que justement
n'est plus on essaie justement de
diminuer ces infractions
[Musique]
donc alors les infractions qu'on
rencontre le plus un juge à ce jour ça
va être infractions concernant la pêche
pêche sous-marine donc qu'il soit dans
le lagon et les pubs la pente externe de
l'autre côté de la barrière et donc
après on
rencontre aussi quelques infractions
fixe au niveau des chiens dans dans le
lagon animaux domestiques dans la
réserve qui sont strictement interdits
et en quelques infractions aussi au
niveau des embarcations de pêche au
niveau de la protection
[Musique]